you
all righty can everyone hear me I'm
talking like a rapper it's working okay
so tonight I want to talk about building
applications like Google using
containers kubernetes and mezzos so just
quick show of hands who here knows what
kubernetes is all right who here knows
what mezzos is I want more hands damn it
anyway so when we hear the term cloud
its kind of overused like yeah everyone
has their own interpretation of what it
means you're starting to see it in
popular marketing and you know it could
mean anywhere from AWS to join into
OpenStack to you know everything in
between and we we talk about containers
docker has really been popularized quite
a bit lately but they've been around for
a while we've had pretty good container
technology with Sun back in 2005 with
the you know Solaris zones but it's more
than just a sandbox but it's a little
bit less than a VM and traditionally
it's pretty lightweight Linux
environment it's hermetically sealed
deployable system it's introspective and
it's a runnable artifact so why should
developers care like static application
environments reliable deployments no
stress deployment no stress deployments
and updates it's repeatable runnable
artifact so it's really portable so you
can develop it on your laptop you know
run it anywhere that you want and
loosely coupled so it's easier to build
and manage you can compose applications
from micro services and mix and extend
third-party services so what we're
really trying to do is keep programs
simple and prefer to build smaller
stateless programs so when I look at
this you know typical row in a data
center I really have no sense of what is
running on those machines right like at
best I have some blinking lights and I
know like yeah something's probably
happening it's blinking so when I look
at the you know a whole cluster I want
to know what's running where and what
it's doing and what resources it's using
in in a typical mm machine cluster you
have you no more than ten machine
crashes per day and that could be
anything from a power supply failing you
know just a disk failure you know
something to cause it to go down so you
see you know RAM failures
that's your averages disk failures
averages machine crashes approximately
you know to a year OS upgrades not
working especially big in a world like
core OS where it can do things in the
background you think everything's great
you go to flip over to the update and
things don't work as expected so I'm
trying to use a different slide deck so
I might not get through all of this but
basically you're talking about hardware
containers cluster management container
management and platform stacks for large
distributed apps and how do you get
started so on Google compute engine you
know you have VMs as a service it's
available in a lot of different
availability zones you've got Europe
Asia u.s. you can do live migrations but
the problems of raw VMs is they're
expensive to turn up it takes a lot of
time for the hypervisor to you know kick
in for the whole system to boot in on
top of that and it's hard to make
repeatable because you actually do have
a whole system booting on top of a
hypervisor there could be things that
can go wrong during that sequence that
you just wouldn't expect like bringing
up a networking stack and you've had a
problem with your DHCP server you're
relying on DHCP and now that machine
doesn't boot and it's really difficult
to replicate locally if you don't have
the exact same underlying hardware
that's being abstracted with that
hypervisor and there's a high
possibility of failure with container
technology it's lightweight linux
execution environment you can use things
like lib container from the folks at
docker lxc you know let me containerize
that for you which by far is my favorite
name that Google came up with because
everything should be named that way I
love seeing a manager look at that be
like
are we ready that LMT super high thing
it's like now no we're not so static
application composition and you have a
reliable deployments and it's really a
unit of resource isolation so you know
multi-tenancy without heavyweight VMs so
docker you know who here uses docker on
a daily basis
really that's it okay who here's used
VMs on a daily basis but not for
production like for development okay
pretty evenly weighted so docker is open
source it's configurable layers it's
reproducible it's version controlled and
you know lots and lots of other people
have containers available at the docker
registry so you can pretty much find
whatever you want you know as a duct as
a docker image and in today's world you
can run everything and you know in
containers pretty much except for some
proprietary software that they don't
want you to run in containers so with
Mentos we support docker it's a
first-class citizen you know you can
scale up to 10,000 plus nodes easily
like if you take Twitter for example all
new development at Twitter is run on top
of mezzos and you're looking at like you
know a hundred thousand plus cores it's
a top-level Apache project just like
Hadoop
it's used by Twitter Airbnb Netflix oh
you name it there's a ton of people
using it and there's api's for c++ the
python jvm languages go obviously and
it's pluggable there's CPU memory and
i/o isolation and it's built on top of
this c group support and linux so you
know you have everything that you can do
with c groups available to you in rezo's
and it's highly configurable we're
pretty easy to use defaults you can
install default package just get up and
running and you can also customize and
and do your own custom frameworks and at
mesosphere we are the company behind
apache mezzos we have the you know Ben
Heineman who's the creator you know
working as our chief architect and
pretty much the majority of the
commuters on the project outside of
Twitter and we are building packages and
support structure for people to run you
know metals on their own on premise
cluster and so I just want to run
through quickly how missiles works
you've got you know application layer
and your framework and the metals master
and a missile slave so on the bezel
slave is where the execution actually
runs where you asks X I couldn't be a
rapper there for a second
so it's where your tasks actually run
and you can see there's one outside
dependency on zookeeper and that's
basically just for the master and the
standbys to decide you know who is the
primary master at that time one
interesting thing about how the mezzo
slaves work is the slave process running
on those boxes it can die and all of
your tasks stay running as soon as you
respawn a new master I mean a new slave
process it just re register x' all of
those tasks that are running and if
anyone's ever tried to do docker at
scale if the docker daemon dies you lose
all of your docker containers and this
is the nice way using our docker
container Iser to avoid that we're
working it's not released
I'll use my safe harbor air quotes here
we have a new version of our docker
container answer that will break away
from that darker daemon dependency so
with kubernetes you you know that's
pretty much uses docker right now is
with a container appointment format and
they promote that it's simple portable
extensible modular it's a framework for
container based services and app
management and it's after internal
systems at Google that managed internet
scale workloads and it's written in go
so who here's looked at the code behind
kubernetes did you like it most part
good stuff so I just briefly wanted to
touch on this slide this is how
kubernetes can run on top of mezzos so
things are broke up you know a little
bit so that we can have the scheduler
running on top of them Bezos master as a
top-level application and the executor
then calling in to let's this might keep
it going out sorry so just a glossary of
terms and kubernetes we have the master
so the managing machine which oversees
one or more minions I love that they use
the term minion I wish would razz those
three as minion instead of slave it
sounds so less demeaning so a minion a
minion is a slave their runs task is
delegated by the user in the kubernetes
master and a pod is an application that
runs on a minion so the replication
controller verifies everything that
should be running is running and then
the label is an arbitrary key value pair
that the replication controller uses for
service discovery so these in Cooper
Nettie's labels are really powerful you
can use that you know to do some really
interesting things for labeling all of
your your different infrastructure and
then you have the the cube config tool
for configuration and the service which
is you know an amalgamation of similar
pods so this slides not the easiest to
read but you can kind of get the basic
overview of how things work your the
REST API everything's pretty easy to
program to you it's pretty extensible
I'm the minion level having C advisor to
actually be able to get stats back about
what's going is pretty powerful tool and
the connection points with kubernetes
running on Amazo says that kubernetes
pods is basically a mezzos task group
the pod labels are a mess those task
group labels and task labels and label
selectors are the using the mussels
label service and I don't know why that
looks so weird the replication
controller is just marathon which is
basically the the scheduling component
from Essos where you decide to kick off
your new tasks and size them and set
their configurations and the equipment
and service is just the marathon service
discovery so the slides showing the
mussels framework overview with Cooper
Nettie's and kind of color coded I don't
know how I you can see that on this one
but so you can see that the mussel slave
actually has the cubelet and the pods so
those are the different containers that
are running there and you have different
executors like the muzzles executors and
here we have a sparks like executors and
what's really interesting about if you
had if you had an existing mezzos
cluster and you were going to also try
out kubernetes you can have marathon you
know side by side with kubernetes you
can have spark you can run everything on
one cluster and at Muslims for what
we're really trying to push is that you
know your whole entire you know data
center acts like just one compute
resource so one of the really exciting
things that we've been working on is
implementing yarn has a mezzo strain
work so it will make an announcement
late probably early next month about
that it's in partnership of some big
names that everyone in the rooms heard
of so now you can pretty much run
everything that you would ever want to
do and you know be the spark job be it
you know I'm trying to emulate your GCE
environment on-premise all on your same
cluster so this was kind of a breakdown
of how the bezels master and scheduler
works so you can coexist with your
current resume work so who here is used
Chronos before anyone like that awesome
you want a job so Cronus is the
distributed cron so you know most
environments you end up seeing you know
pretty ridiculous setup so you have one
box that's named like cron one you know
like you take Airbnb for example back in
their legacy Prima's those days they had
two boxes one name cron one name one
name cron two and when a new developer
would be hired they'd go and add their
job everything was great their editor
would be configured to remove blank
lines and they would screw up the whole
crontab because they didn't realize
there had to be a blank line at the
bottom and the job that was supposed to
run on a Monday night didn't run it all
and nothing got updated it was a pain so
the people at MMB started to make a
project called Chronos which runs on top
of mezzos and actually just you know
uses the whole cluster to make sure that
your jobs are scheduled and run on time
and the the mezzo semester has an
interesting concept to for fairness so
it's DRF base so dominant resource
fairness between frameworks so it's as
the frameworks are written they actually
have weights applied to them so that you
can make sure that you know your things
run in conjunction with other things on
the cluster and that's just an approach
that we've taken and there's other ways
that you could you could architect that
but a really interesting use case from
one of our customers we have a major
hedge fund that uses our system and each
one of their data scientists as they're
working on their algorithms actually
implement them as custom frameworks and
depending
how well their algorithm did that day
the fair the fairness algorithm is
tweaked and they get more compute
resources so the better the rate their
algorithm the better the output they get
the more compute resources they get so
there's kind of like you know if you
suck at your job you get no compute
resources and your job never finishes
and maybe you don't work there anymore
and that was a pretty interesting thing
having your people fight like I could
just imagine what those guys are saying
to each other like hey I got 12% of the
cluster today what did you get o 8%
that's pretty sad Wow anyone know where
this is actually plugged in I got none
of the cluster right there alright so
moving right along so in the meso
spoiled the Maslov is actually you know
the the machine that's gonna do all the
executions so you can kind of see the
breakdown here and a little closer
detail of how the tasks are run so in a
pure asos world with docker you'd have
your docker container you'd use marathon
to register that you would say that you
need this amount of CPU this amount of
disk this amount of memory and the slave
that could handle that running that
container would you know basically be
given that task and say run this
container so in our proprietary version
with the arm what we call the mesosphere
manager you imagine that was your go app
and you have that inside of a docker
container you launch one and all of our
metrics are exposed via a REST API so
you could write custom your own custom
framework to look at like the inbound
traffic to that go app and decide that
okay if I get to this threshold I need
one more two more three more and with
marathon you can actually orchestrate
all of those together so you can say
things like okay so for every four
versions of my you know go app running I
need two more Redis servers and you can
orchestrate all those containers being
brought up together and so we basically
map all those concepts on top of the
kubernetes
and one thing to note with mezzos is
you're not stuck we'll just you know the
docker container format you have you can
run raw tasks you can see here like just
kicking off a jar file or a war file you
know directly basically you know you
could have a bash script that you're
kicking off it doesn't have to be a full
on you know container tap so what does
messes contribute on top of kubernetes
so you've got the multi framework
weighted fair sharing roles preemption
and no drain which are in development so
one thing to note about our project is
those top-level Apache projects so you
have all of the kind of inherent latency
of getting things approved and code
reviewed so what we have running
internally versus what's on review board
and waiting for approval sometimes there
can be a bit of a delay but you know
these concepts are really interesting
the the preemption in the node drain so
being able to do things like okay I want
to add more storage to you know do these
boxes you can actually go ahead and you
imagine you're running MySQL and you had
it running on a couple of your slaves
and you wanted to now have you know
three petabytes instead of one petabyte
you'd have to drain the workload off of
those get everything going on something
else add that physical storage and then
bring everything back up so we're we
basically have a seamless way to do that
now and you can rent pods alongside
other frameworks so you could actually
have you know who do running on top of
your Maysles cluster as well as your
pods that emulate your your GC
environment so you know spark well this
place rails of the board go ahead you
and you can run services and batch apps
on the same cluster so we really want to
push on that that the mesosphere stack
is the you know OS for the data center
and you don't have to think about
individual machines any longer and a
really concrete example of that is that
Twitter so in the past it would take to
you know maybe two to two and a half
months to bring a new service up you had
to get Hardware provision do you have to
get you know all the configuration
handled and that would take a long time
you had to go through the whole QA so I
go get things approved
now you can literally take you know a
container get it approved in QA and
blessed and run it on the production
cluster within 20 minutes of when you
had it approved QA so the other things
that mezzos contributes as the advanced
scheduling for resources constraints and
a global view of everything that's
happening so one of our newer
advancements and mezzos is the mezzo CLI
so you can actually do things like PS
tree against the whole cluster and see
what all of your containers and all of
your different slaves you know are doing
in one kind of unified view you have
high resource availability and cluster
self-healing so with the different
frameworks that we have we have
proprietary frameworks commercial
frameworks from other people and just
community frameworks and if you look at
like the elastic search framework it's
really interesting because they have
that concept of self-healing so if
you've ever had to try to run an elastic
search on your own you can see like you
can really easily get into a state where
things aren't the greatest where if you
just run it on top of mezzos with that
framework that goes away and you don't
even realize you have problems and it's
proven at scale and battle-tested in
production I mean if you look at there's
two different fortune 20 companies that
I can't name the names of that are I've
switched over to him as those cluster
and you've got Twitter Airbnb Netflix
all these other people using it so you
kind of feel more comfortable of trying
it out in your environment because I
doubt you or some of you in the room
maybe have huge infrastructures but you
know for the average infrastructure for
most startups it's it's more than enough
and you know really concrete use case
that showcase our case study that
showcases that is you know HubSpot was
spending about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a month in their
premium as those days on their AWS bill
and they were able to get up and convert
all over their services to running on
top of mezzos in about three months and
their first bill the month after they
switched over to mezzos was 65% less
than their bill had been traditionally
you know all the months before and
they've actually been able to handle
double the amount of traffic than they
did before using 30% less
resources and month-over-month they keep
getting better with that and you know
the other thing is just having the CLI
tools that match the the GUI so you're
not you have you prefer gooeys you can
have a full GUI experience if you love
CL eyes you could do that as well so and
does anyone have any questions I don't
want to keep running through slides
anything nothing boring awesome so what
does kubernetes contributed so pods no
tasks to collate loco to co-locate
deploy isolate and replicate the label
service which is the arbitrary metadata
for tasks and pods which is actually I
mentioned earlier I think is actually a
really cool thing so with the
attribution system it mezzos let's say
you had pretty much all the same
hardware for all of your slaves but and
a couple of them you had some Tesla you
know K 40 GPUs in there and you had some
Tara sorts that you wanted to do you
could actually use this label service or
the attributes in mezzos and you know
define that so you wouldn't want tasks
that don't need GPUs on on slaves that
have GPUs and you could target that or
if you had really beefy machines you
could apply labels that say like these
are only for the offices of the CTO or
only for these special jobs in
emergencies so you could always
guarantee that you know when your boss's
boss's boss need something done it runs
so speedy and he talks about how amazing
the cluster is and with kubernetes you
get this tightly integrated service
discovery solution so they really
thought about things at scale at Google
and and how to tie things together and
that's the really critical missing piece
just with you know docker and trying to
do the orchestration now is there's no
really super solid service discovery and
everyone seems to have a slightly
different take on what service discovery
means and encompasses and then the
ability to run the kubernetes api
workloads
so this is a horrible slide and I
apologize for how it looks but you know
I'm not an artist so you can see you
know and this slide shows GC off in the
corner you've got
hold on a second
okay so you know you've got a hardware
fault tolerance with GCE with dr. you've
got easy packaging you know update some
isolation of your app we've mezzos you
have the scalability elasticity
multi-tenancy batch jobs you know full
utilization of the hardware and with
kubernetes you get that high
availability of the service discovery
and the surface accurate aggregation so
this really allows you to have Google
like computing for everyone so you know
you can decide to use your whole your
whole cluster so who here is heard of
Google borg before okay
so Google is in the process now moving
over to Omega which is their you know
next-generation Borg and you kind of get
the best of both worlds with kubernetes
on top of meso so you can do things and
the kind of older paradigm you can
architect things a little bit closer to
the Omega patterns that that they're
moving towards now and you know just to
kind of show some possible stack
variations you can have you know
marathon running next to kubernetes on
top of GCE and it's you know Google's
hardware and Linux underneath and one of
the things I really like about mezzos is
that portability like if you think of
the mesos as a kernel sitting on top of
all of your Linux machines it doesn't
really matter to me where those Linux
machines are underneath so if you have
everything in docker containers you're
using marathon to kick them off it
doesn't matter to me if you're on AWS
digitalocean GCE you know on-premise
because it's all gonna work across all
of that so it allows you to do some
interesting hybrid you know solutions so
then you just get to basically data data
locality issues like obviously you don't
want to be running something in AWS and
accessing data on-premise because it
just wouldn't be very performant so you
know kind of showing another stack
variation you know the other hardware
cloud providers different types of Linux
core OS
and you have that affordability there's
no vendor lock-in in the future we have
a strategic relationship with the Korres
folks and we're trying to build you know
a better version of chorus that works
tightly with mezzos but it really
doesn't matter to us as long as you have
a modern Linux you know kernel you can
run everything and in Razzles we have
the concept of Isolators so you could
write your own custom Isolators for
example so if let's say you had some
secret sauce and you're doing some
better you know you're the hedge fund
and you're doing some better
floating-point calculations utilizing
you know GPUs for example you could
actually you know implement that at the
isolator level and provide that to your
services so these are just some static
screenshots to show you what the you
know Google cloud platform with Meadows
looks like if you go to google that
mesosphere comm you can go through the
process and bring up your own cluster so
you just choose the configuration for
your cluster if it's development or
actually high availability you see the
costs are are fairly low but also small
instance counts go through fill up the
forms and then launch the cluster and
gives you kind of the cost per hour I
believe we still have credits available
for this so if anyone actually wants to
try things out on GC we can get you a
$500 credit so you can you know have you
know in a development environment 500
bucks so take you a long way when it's
$1 in 68 per hour
so once the cluster is launching you can
see you know when it's provisioned then
through the you know the Google
developer console you can see what the
boxes are where they're located what the
external IP s are now your cluster is
ready to go you can access it to the
cluster VPN using an Open VPN client and
start to run tasks so you can see this
development cluster and it's been up for
this in my time nothing is really
running on it so in summary you can
complete build a complete stack for
large distributed apps you truly have
multi-tenancy and really good resource
optimization and it's easy to deploy
with no vendor lock-in
so these are just some links you know
obviously GCE equip Nettie's mesosphere
and then like Cooper Nissan rezo's
framework which is still in heavy active
development we have a strategic
partnership of Google you know to try to
provide this and obviously being able to
run on premise or even in your own you
know cloud provider that's not GCE and
test things out and it know that you're
doing it in a way that will run really
well on GCE
it's pretty powerful for a lot of
startups and smaller organizations and
some photo credits because they don't
like to just take photos so at this
point if anyone has any questions I'd
love to answer them
yeah so you know like asterisk the
kubernetes still pre-production you know
beta software it's not not meant to be
used in production but service discovery
for them is very terse and the way that
that they describe it you you're using
that labeling system to you know define
what ports what services are running
where and kind of laying out the whole
pattern of what things look like this is
my container that's running my go app
this is my can hands for any Redis these
are how they communicate you know in
these ports and we are probably gonna
take a little broader approach will
service discovery when it comes to to
mesos we referring to it as service net
but we want to give people the ability
to actually do more than just define you
know this protocol on this port like the
ability to have a module from like an
intrusion detection vendor and things
like that and be able to do packet
inspection and look at like the payloads
so like even though you're you know you
think you're talking to my SQL make sure
that actually is you know that type of
data being sent over the wire if you
look at the repo for kubernetes they
have really good walkthroughs of
everything then there's actually a
section on service discovery so you can
get really granular details on it and
did you know if you have any questions
feel free to email either people at
mussel spirit people at Google and we
can go into it in more detail and also
since it is you know a very actively
developed project opening up an issue if
you see something that doesn't make
sense and getting some of the core
developers actually to help you makes a
lot of sense and you know if you see
anything that you think is this may be a
little awkward pattern or wouldn't work
in your environment you know kind of
defining that scenario will help as well
to shape it to be more what you need so
anyone else have any questions
yeah
so you're not really running the tasks
outside of Seagram's you're running them
outside of the container
so what Maz will she have this container
Iser there's just a generic container
Iser so you can launch anything that you
can run on Linux you know that way so
you could have a shell script a jar file
you know whatever you want to run and
we've seen interesting patterns that
people do like for example right now
Oracle's not supported inside of any
kind of the container formats but we see
people that will take five of their
slaves and that's their Oracle RAC
servers but they still use marathon to
schedule the actual Oracle process
running even though they have all of the
prerequisites for Oracle they don't try
to throw that in a container so they
don't violate their license but they
have the ability to say you know if I
need to rebalance or I need to do this
thing I can bring up 15 more you know to
do that and not violate my license as
long as I don't go past this like time
threshold so you know there's no hard
constraints of how you can do things so
any other questions in the back
so for example you bring up that cluster
you then you know you could either use
the marathon scheduling and and go ahead
and you call those rest api's and set up
your containers and run their or you
could do it the kubernetes way through
that that UI so whatever you would you
know be trying to run you could bring up
so one of the things we did recently at
mesosphere is we took five of our new
engineers that were going through the
onboarding process and we put them in a
co-working space outside of our office
and we said you know pretend you're a
new startup and you're trying to bring
up what you think is a typical stack but
you're only requirements is that you
have to use docker and you have to use
mesos and it has to work and they went
away for three days for this kind of dog
food and exercise and came up with way
to bring everything up and then we
basically took you know we tried to
break it after they showed what they
built and it was pretty amazing to me
that like these guys are they were low
in you know kernel developer type guys
so they you know bitched about things
that all of us probably are willing to
deal with like I can't believe how hard
it is to run this Hadoop installer it's
like all right whatever but they but
they got everything working and some of
the new things that we're adding and
medals that I'm really excited about is
some new primitives for stateful apps so
you won't have to do static reservations
for things like HDFS you'll be able to
have you know things like Cassandra HDFS
MySQL all running without you having to
statically say like these are the slaves
that will do this you can actually do it
a much saner way and it probably be q1
of next year where that's released and
available but you know back to your
question like whatever you want to run
on the cluster you can one thing I
really like about the GC environment is
it seems like the costs are are pretty
low and getting that five hundred dollar
credit gives you a good opportunity to
play around with things and in
comparison to some of the other
providers that we we have turnkey
elastic mezzos solutions on the
performance seems really great
especially if you can get yourself in on
one of the SSD backed machines any other
questions anyone none okay no one wanted
like a shouldn't my slides prettier